two former Liverpool teammates reunited
on new ground Jordan Henderson and sadio
manea are among the top players to have
swapped Europe's top leagues for the
Saudi pro league with Henderson now at
Al etifac and Manet signing for
Cristiano Ronaldo's al-nasa this week
they'll get the first taste of Saudi
football as the new season begins the
excitement is definitely palpable
um in this football mad country right
where football is in the DNA for us
really this is a moment when the
strategy actually comes together and
comes to life
that strategy started with Ronaldo's
arrival at al-nasa late last year since
then the government has backed the Saudi
pro league investing billions to make
clubs more professional aimed at making
the league one of the best in the world
at the start of the transfer window
Ballon d'Or winner Karim Benzema signed
for al-itahad from Real Madrid and since
then there's been an influx of foreign
players the clubs have shelled Out close
to half a billion dollars and football
website transfer marked ranks the Saudi
league as the fifth biggest spender in
the window behind leagues in Italy
France Germany and England this is
definitely a journey this is not us just
a one weekend
we've set off to to achieve this
objective to to be one of the top 10
leaks in the world
Saudi Arabia has made big Investments
across sport including in golf boxing
and formula one although critics such as
Amnesty International are accusing the
kingdom of sports washing their human
rights record
but that hasn't put off broadcasters
from buying up the rights to show Saudi
football in more than 170 countries
while fans in the capital Riyadh are
also preparing for a bigger and better
season ahead
in the past we got used to the
competition being between Al hilal and
al-nasa or al-hil Al and al-itihad but
this year the presence of international
players like Benzema Cristiano and Neves
in the Saudi League will give more
excitement and competition between clubs
the International Players one or two
years back were in the biggest clubs and
were considered among the greatest
players in the world so I'm extremely
happy to see our national league and an
Arabic league with these names this is a
beautiful thing
the season kicks off on Friday but the
transfer window is open until the first
week of September and the feeling is
that the Saudi pro league may still
attract another big name before it
closes Joanna gajroska Al Jazeera
foreign